[Music]
is focused
it's focused I just want to be kind in
this morning everybody who's spewing
negativity and trying to tear down
others and their own insecurity I'm
coming for you you've got a problem now
I'm a different dude after all
this stuff you have to understand you're
in deep trouble I'm coming for
you I'm suffocating you I've been
putting pressure on you that's why
you've gotten louder I'm coming with
straight love and compassion piece by
piece strategy by strategy decision by
decision execution by execution I'm
gonna get you
hiding in the corners of Twitter and
Discord and Instagram DMS and in the
comments I see every one of you and your
cynicism and your negativity is in
deeper trouble than ever before because
I'm more motivated than ever I'm more
focused than ever I'm stronger than ever
and I'm gonna get you you
understand signed scary
ready